こんにちは！オレ、ハトシ！
今年で24歳になるポケモントレーナー！
今日も世界中にいる不思議なポケモンを見つけて
冒険中の真っ只中！
あ、冒険…同じ意味だわw
どこかにポケモンいないかな？
こういうトンネルとかにもポケモンがいるからな！
キャァーーーッ！(視聴者の悲鳴)
オレ変質者かよマジで
ポケモンのためならオレは森の中へでも行くぜ！
カッコイイだろ！
でも、ポケモントレーナーは
お金にならないから、ひもじい思いをしているよ！
（子供たちの笑い声）
服装が変だから子供たちにいじめられる！
でも俺は諦めない！
（ポケモンの出現音）
伝説のポケモンマスターになるまで！
っしゃ、ポケモンきたー！
（スマホの振動音）
っしゃ、捕まえるぞー！
（タマタマの鳴き声）
よし、いくぞー！
タイミングを狙って！
（タマタマの鳴き声）
いけモンスターボール！
くっそ！
んあっっ！
なんだこいつは！
（タマタマの鳴き声）
んんっっ！
（ハトシ発狂）
（スマホの振動音）
っしゃ、ポケモンきたー！
あ…！ギャロップだ！
こいつはなんとか捕まえたい！
んなっっ！
ジャイロボール！
遠いなぁ
（スマホの振動音）
っしゃ、ポケモンきたー！
あっ！ヘイガニだ！
ルビーサファイアのポケモンなのに！
これは捕まえたいなあ
いくぜ！モンスターボール！
でゃぁっ！
おっ！きた！
捕まるか？
（ハトシ沈黙）
あれ？
あ、バグだこれ
これバグだわ
（スマホの振動音）
っしゃ、ポケモンきたー！
バンギラスだ！
こいつだけは捕まえなければ！
ポケモンマスターの名が…廃るぜ！
よしこれは、今だ！
はっ！
くそっ、攻撃してきやがる！
んんっ！
くっ！くそっ！くそっ！
（ハトシの険しい表情）
どわぁぁーー！
あっはっはっはぁー！
…帰ろ
[ED]
（スマホの振動音）
っしゃ、ポケモンきたー！
エアームドだ！
捕まえたい！
くそっ、うっ、ううっ
んんっ！
はっ！
くっ…
くそっ！
空飛ぶぅ…
これでどうだ！
くっ…
でゃぁっ！
そんな飛びますか！